what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down today I think I have the
most viral man on the internet right now
welcome to the show God sad introduce
yourself to the people uh well thank you
for having me it's a pleasure to be with
you my name is Gad sad I'm a professor
behavioral scientist author and uh
apparently a provoc although I don't try
to provoke people but in today's world
of political correctness anything you
you say or do somehow anger someone so
here I am yeah I saw you on Pierce
Morgan recently you went you went so
crazy viral what was that like for
you well yeah you know it's not the
first time that that's happened because
I've been you know in the public eye for
a while you know I went many times on
Joe Rogan that also tends to get a lot
of attention Megan Kelly so uh I think
what's unique about what's happening
these days is that a lot of the viral
nature comes with a lot of I mean
positive but also a lot of hate right
because the the issue that I was
discussing on Pierce Morgan was of
course you know Jew hatred and the
Middle East and Israel and Gaza and so
on and so it becomes very easy even if
you're very measured and reasoned and
rational and professorial for someone to
be angry at you so you take the good and
the bad most people are super sweet but
a few are not so sweet yeah well I
thought it was even cool um not not so
much cuz I'm not too much into like the
political what's going on over there I I
don't know too much about it but um what
I thought was cool was you guys did the
long sit down interview after where you
really like explained each other's point
of views he came out to Canada didn't he
no no I think you might be mixing me up
with someone else uh no you you might be
thinking about uh an Egyptian guy who
some say looks like me so that's not me
I don't mean to put you on the spot but
he did go to see him
in oh I totally thought that someone
told me that you did that I'm sorry no
no that's uh no no that's that's an
Egyptian guy who apparently we look
alike he's Egyptian I'm Lebanese but we
don't stand on the same side of that
issue so there you go okay um okay so
you wrote a book on
happiness um could you tell me a little
bit about
that well if you would have asked me
three years ago so my my last book prior
to the happiness book was the parasitic
mind and it had been a a big success and
if you would have asked me what's my
next project going to be I would have
never told you back then that it would
be unhappiness and so this is one of
those serendipitous things that happens
where I would get a lot of emails from
people saying hey how come what's your
secret to always being Smiley and you're
playful and you know you joke around
even though you're dealing with serious
issues what's your secret to happiness
professor and then the second thing that
I would get often which led me to think
about writing this book is that people
would write to me that some advice that
I gave on you know Twitter or wherever
on some show was profoundly impactful to
their life let's say I I lost a lot of
weight during Co so I might talk about
that and then someone will say well I
just lost 30 pounds because you
motivated me to do so and so when I saw
the kind of you know positive impact
that I can have I said well why don't I
take a crack at actually answering
people's question of what is the secret
to happiness and that's what led me to
write the book but it was a bit daunting
because probably the topic that's been
most covered by philosophers for several
Millennia is exactly the topic of
happiness and the good life and so the
the challenge was to make sure that I
would come up with something uh you know
fresh and unique and distinct and if
I've done a good job hopefully that's
what you'll think if you read the book
MH well especially today in 2023 it's so
interesting because we have the highest
standard of living like really than ever
in all of human history but we have more
mental health issues like you just see
people going crazy left and right yeah I
think it's because in part a lot so I I
don't know if your viewers and listeners
know but my my area of scientific
research is uh evolutionary psychology
or more generally evolutionary
Behavioral Sciences what are the
evolutionary mechanisms that have led to
why our minds operate the way that they
do why do we have certain preferences
that and and and I know that you talk a
lot about you know male female Dynamics
and of course that's all within the
purview of evolutionary psychology and
so one of the things that makes us
unhappy in the Contemporary world is a
misalignment between something that was
adaptive in our evolutionary past and
something that becomes maladaptive in
the Contemporary environment so example
we've evolved to be in small bands of
about 150 people people where everybody
knows each other well we have strong
bonds of reciprocity we really bond with
one another now you put someone in
London where you are or in New York
where you're surrounded by tons of
people so you would think it's difficult
to be lonely but reality is you don't
have these strong bonds so even in an
city of eight or 10 million people you
could feel incredibly lonely and
isolated and so one of the things I talk
about in the book is this mis mismatch
between what our evolutionary
environment was like and what our modern
environment is like and how that
mismatch can result in
unhappiness wow that makes perfect sense
actually because I hated living in
London when I first got here I hated it
for so
long and so you're saying but now you
now you like it
um better I used to it's it's okay I I'm
I'm from more of like the country so it
was a really big because I was recruited
to play volleyball here so yeah so it
was a really big um I guess adaptation
like I've never lived in a big city
before so that kind of actually makes a
lot of sense as to why I didn't like it
yeah so it's basically is it too many
people for us to process or how does
that work yeah so the the idea of why
the number 150 is so important it's
actually it's it comes from a British
evolutionary Anthropologist his name is
Robin Dunbar so this has become known as
dunbar's number the idea is that
our our brain has a maximal
computational capacity to maintain
relationships with up to 15 people now
why is that because with 150 people I
can tag everyone who is for example a
social cheater let's suppose you and I
Pearl are in the same 150 people I
invite you 10 times to dinner as a
friend but you never reciprocate well
now I could tag the fact that Pearl is a
social chief cheat and that even though
I I'm always exhibiting cues of
generosity to her she never reciprocates
well it becomes very difficult to tag
each of the people that you're having
meaningful relationships once you exceed
about 150 and so the optimal size for
many things military divisions business
divisions the number of people that we
typically send Christmas cards to the
number of people at the average wedding
they all seem to be exactly around 150
and so that's why this has become known
as dunbar's number because for many
types of maximally flourishing groups of
people it hovers around 150 well that
makes so much sense because I've
interviewed so many people for like
shows so it's so confusing to me because
it's like all of the like especially for
um like panel shows it'll be like people
I've met before but I'll like I don't
you know or you might even confuse me
with an Egyptian guy
I would never never do that um wait so
does that mean our brains are kind of
messed up because of social media
because you're almost having like a cuz
it's kind of a weird thing and I'm sure
you've experienced this when you get a
level of Fame where you'll have people
that almost feel like they're friends
with you but you don't know who like you
don't know them so it's almost like a
one-sided like they've listened to hours
and hours of you talking but then it's
it's like a really weird thing once you
get to a certain like it's I I can't
even you you probably know it's a weird
phenomen you're exactly right because I
get I get approached as you might
Imagine by a lot of people on the street
almost always incredibly positive but
they do speak to me exactly to your
point with a level of in intimacy which
at first kind of takes me a back like
let's suppose you know I you know we
used we we used to have Belgian
Shepherds as as our you know pets we we
love Belgian Shepherd dogs and when our
last Belgian Shepherd passed away you
know I had gone you know on social media
to say that you know my beautiful
Belgian Queen had just passed away so
someone will come up to you whom you've
never met and say oh you know I really I
was touched by you know I'm very sorry
for your loss and at first you're
thinking but I don't know you how do you
know this and then then you think oh
it's probably because I shared it on
Twitter and a million people have SE so
so yes there is definitely as you said
an asymmetry of of intimacy plus I think
there's something unique about I think I
think what both you and I do which is as
you said people if they consume your
content on a regular basis you really
are in their bedroom or you're going for
a jog with them or you're you're in
there and they're you know or or they
download the thing in your podcast and
you're speaking straight to their brain
and so there's a level of intimacy that
comes with this kind of public
engagement which in most cases is
positive but at times it could be a bit
creepy yeah no but I meant like does
that make people more more lonely in a
way because on the other hand it's
like influencers almost replace I'd
imagine almost replace personal
relationships at
times I mean I think definitely that
that could be true uh you know social
media like most things uh in life has
positives and negatives uh of course
there are all sorts of negatives that
that we all know it it opens you up to
all sorts of hate if you're a young
person and someone starts attacking you
and you don't yet have the strong
personhood to withstand it that could
send you into a really miserable Abyss
uh but on the other hand social media
has afforded me the opportunity to
connect with people that our worlds
would have never intersected I mean How
likely would you and I have ever met
would I you know would you have ever
known of me would I have ever known of
you were it not for social media and so
I've had a chance to meet you you know
all sorts of incredible people some I'll
just give you one quick example which
actually I discussed in the in the
happiness book uh one of my probably my
favorite uh musical band of all time is
is part of a genre of music called
Philly sound which is a type of Soul
music that came out of uh Philadelphia
in the in the 70s in late 60s early 70s
I I was a very young child then well the
top group within that genre is a group
called The Stylistics You know that that
I used to listen to even when I was
growing up in Lebanon uh you know as a
kid who didn't even understand English
yet and fast forward to a few years ago
well I met and became friends with the
lead singer of The Stylistics he's about
20 years older than me but I simply
couldn't believe that a guy that you
know I I did a slow you know I was slow
dancing to In in first year high school
is a guy that now I'm hanging around
with in Philadelphia so yes social media
has a lot of traps but it also opens you
up to the world in ways that that is
truly magical so why do you think
there's so many mental health issues
today well it's a it's like many things
it's a
multifactorial uh you know explanation
uh are you talking about a particular
demographic group or age group because I
think the answer to what you asked
depends on which age group I'm
in just generally or well I would just
say um my dad I just when I talk to my
dad um cuz my dad's in his 50s he he'll
just kind of tell me that the world used
to be a lot different like people were
friendlier there was less like mental
health issues going around um would you
say that's
inaccurate I mean uh there might be a a
slight increase in in mental health
issues but again it depends on which
type of mental health uh there is an
increase even anecdotally in anxiety
disorders but as a professor I can tell
you that in many cases students game
that process right whereby now you know
you know I've been a professor now for
30 this is my 30th year so I've had a
chance to see you know generations of
students come and go and it seems quite
extraordinary that the number of
students who now file for uh special
accommodations for
Disabilities is quite shocking so uh in
part it might indeed be due to an
increase in some of these mental health
issues but I don't want to sound cynical
but in many cases I think because people
have learned to game the system so
example uh is there really such a thing
as exam taking anxiety well that's also
called life right so uh you know uh you
know that you know I I I simply I I have
mental health crisis if I have to take
an exam because it's too stressful I
mean give me a break right so of course
there are real things of you know real
anxiety uh real panic attacks real
phobias uh I even you know published
papers on this in the academic
literature but it's also a bit of we
live in an orgiastic victimology culture
where everybody has a disability and you
know you know I when I was a child I was
ducking 17 ways that I was about to die
during the Lebanese Civil War so
boohoohoo somebody misgendered you or or
it's tough to take an exam so it's a bit
of both I think yes there life has maybe
gotten a bit more difficult but it's
also a lot of gaming of the system so
you think it's it's sort of like they're
expanding the definition of maybe like
they wouldn't have been classified as
like depressed in the past but now
they're classifying them exactly and
there's actually in in in my previous
book not the happiness one but in the
parasitic mind I exactly talk about that
where I uh discuss what what constitutes
now a a a valid case of you being a
victim right uh
and and I I hate to say it but to your
point many times people you know
classify themselves as victims only
because it has now become the means by
which you ascend the social hierarchy in
the past maybe when your
dad I'm I'm presuming about your dad's
age uh meritocracy was the means by
which we adjudicated who gets to the top
of the hierarchy you know you're a
better volleyball player well you make
the team and I don't you're a better
soccer player you're a better scientist
at so it's based on Merit whereas today
I'm sure probably some of your viewers
and listeners know where I reside in
Academia what matters most is what my
gender identity is what's my skin color
is whether I'm transgender or not
whether I'm indigenous or not that's a
terrible way to be organizing science
what makes science beautiful is that it
doesn't care about your personal
identity it doesn't care about your uh
victimology story right mathematics is
mathematics whether I'm tall or short
gay or straight transgender or not and
so uh so yes there are some things from
our past that I long for but there are
other things that are better today so
what happened to Academia like what why
has it gone so
crazy well uh so that's now we're moving
from the happiness book maybe we'll come
back to happiness but uh now we go back
to the previous book The parasitic mind
where I basically argued that so let me
give the bit of a background if you grab
me a bit of leeway so in in nature there
are parasites that parasitize a host so
for example a tapeworm parasitizes your
intestinal tract okay a neurop parasite
is one that goes to the host's brain
Alters its circuitry to suit to Su suit
its interest so and I I'm doing all this
to come back to your question but just
give me a second so for example the wood
cricket
is a cricket that hates water it never
wants to jump in water but when it is
parasitized by a particular type of
neurop parasite called a hairworm the
hairworm needs the wood Cricut to jump
into the water because in order for it
to to complete its reproductive cycle
that needs to happen in water and
therefore the wood Cricut who typically
abhor water will merily suicidally jump
into water because its brain has been
parasitized by this hair warm okay so I
take this framework and I argue in this
book The Yellow Book the parasitic mind
that in the same way that animals and
humans could be parasitized by actual
brain worms they could be parasitized by
a second class of worms and I call these
idea pathogens or parasitic ideas hence
why I call the book The parasitic mind
so postmodernism radical feminism
cultural relativism social
constructivism these are all IDE
pathogens that are perfectly in
congruent with reality with science with
common sense but to your point so now I
come to your question all of these
Dreadful ideas were originally spawned
within the university ecosystem because
it takes intellectuals to come up with
some of the stupidest ideas and so what
I do in the book basically is I describe
all of these idea pathogens and then
toward the end of the book I offer a
mind vaccine how can we inoculate
ourselves against this kind of stupidity
so that's the problem with Academia is
that many academics exist in a rarified
world where they are perfectly decoupled
from reality right so they so they could
sit on top of their you know Podium
pontificate all kinds of but
there isn't a mechanism that's autoc
corrective that slaps them back into
reality so that's what allows me then to
say that tall is short left is Right
male is female a penis is a form of
vagina and on and on and on it's
precisely these parasitic ideas that are
altering the neural circuitry of people
that causes them to jump into the abyss
of infinite
lunacy well you know my dad actually
said something to me about that he told
me like the smart like the smartest
people he's ever met were actually
stupid and I didn't understand it when I
was younger but then the older I get the
more I see a lot of like smart people
are pushing these ideas um and some of
it it's kind of like common sense but
how do you sift through and understand
like who is pushing and who is
pushing things that are actually true
well uh somebody who says that uh men
too can menstruate is likely pushing
somebody who says men too can
uh bear children is likely right so I
mean we all are endowed with you know a
instinctual ability to reason and
navigate the world and once you're
starting to see just an orgastic form of
existential gaslighting then you know
that that person is probably pushing
so I I'll tell you this is a
story that maybe you haven't heard so it
might be worth repeating here for and I
suspect many of your audience haven't
heard it it it's going to capture the
extent to which some areas of Academia
are are utterly lost so this is a story
that happened in 20 2002 Pearl so this
is way before the transgender craze way
before you know men too can have
cervical cancer and all this kind of
okay so this was 2002 I one of
my doctoral students had just uh
defended his his dissert doctoral
dissertation so we were going out to
dinner to celebrate and at that dinner
there was going to be me my wife him and
he was bringing a date along a female
date
and so he calls me a few hours before we
head out to dinner and he says oh I just
wanted to give you a heads up that the
lady that I'm bringing along she's a
graduate student in post-modernism
women's studies and cultural
anthropology to which I answered ah I
got it the Holy Trinity of uh
so then he says you know but you know
let's have I said oh no no I got you
this is your night I'm going to be on my
best behavior I'm going to be a good boy
which of course was a abject lie because
about half halfway through the evening I
turned to the lady in in question and I
said oh I hear you're you're a
postmodernist she said yes uh by the way
she was she was a graduate student in
postmodernism at one of the most
prestigious universities a Canadian
University but one of the most
prestigious universities in the world so
you can probably guess what the top two
three Canadian universities are so it's
not that she was at some quack school I
said okay so there are no postmodernism
posits that there are no no absolute
universals there are no absolute truths
correct she says yes I said okay well do
you mind if I propose what I think is a
universal and then you can correct me
she said yeah go for it this is 2002
Pearl right so this is 21 years ago I
said okay well is it not true that for
Homo sapiens for humans only women bear
children so she looks at me she couldn't
believe that I was this dumb this
simpleton professor she said no that's
absolutely not true I said it's not true
that only women children how so she said
well because there's some Japanese tribe
off some Japanese island whereby within
their mythological folkloric realm it is
The Men Who bear children so by you
keeping us barefoot and pregnant with
your biological essentialism that's how
you you know you promulgate your sexist
stuff so once I recovered from the
minist stroke I had at listening to such
I then said okay well maybe I
picked a an example that's a bit too
controversial like arguing that you know
only women can bear children what can I
take a shot at another example she said
yes go for it I said is it not true
since time immemorial that Sailors have
relied on the premise that the sun rises
in the East and sets in the west is that
not a universal so there she used a
variant of postmodernism it's called
deconstructionism language creates
reality there is no reality outside of
language so she goes what do you mean by
east and west and what do you mean by
the Sun what you might call the sun I
might call exact words dancing hyena I
said well fine the dancing hyena rises
in the East and sets in the west and she
said well I don't play those label games
why do I always repeat that story
because it is a perfect
encapsulation of what happens to a mind
when it is parasitized by some of the
nonsense taught at universities if a
grown adult adult woman is sitting down
with a professor and we can't agree that
women only bear children and that there
is such a thing as east and west and
this thing called the sun if we can't
agree on that where else can we go to
it's a dead end and so yes your father
was right some of the dumbest people are
some of the most educated people no
that's what they always do oh my gosh
you triggered me a little bit okay you
triggered me because they do this to me
on the show I'll say something like men
don't like fat chicks and they'll tell
me about this tribe in like the middle
of like some I'm so tired of hearing
about this tribe in Africa where like I
like I I I want to go there because I
just like don't even believe it exists
maybe I think I actually know which
tribe it is oh oh you do I I bet you I
know which one it's probably the Huda
tribe uh it because there is a well
there are several tribes but there is a
tribe in Africa where on average the men
prefer heavier women but the reason why
their preferences change itself is due
to an evolutionary adaptation because in
environments that have been typically
defined by endemic caloric scarcity then
men will shift their preferences in an
Adaptive manner right but now what is
still true in the those cultures where
they might prefer the women to be
heavier what is universal across all
those different cultures is that men
will still prefer a woman that has the
hourglass figure so it's so so you could
be thinner and still have The Hourglass
or you could be fatter and still have
the Hour Glass figure what those
imbeciles that tell you these things on
on your show or other shows what they
won't tell you they'll never tell you oh
we found a culture where men prefer
women who look like men male Olympic
swimmers that culture doesn't exist it
doesn't exist because there is no
evolutionary reason for men to ever
evolve that preference so not
withstanding that they're telling you
this they're only proving The
evolutionary imperative that that men
and women's preferences for their ideal
Mates is inscribed in our genes well and
I don't understand why they go to the
ends of the Earth to find like the one
exception on the planet and that and I'm
I I was I'm triggered by this matriarchy
I keep hearing about some matriarchy
tribe in I I think it's also in Africa
where I guess I guess it's like a but
I'm like why why do they keep when
everywhere else I'll tell I'll there's a
couple of answers to that because I've
spent 30 years in my scientific career
dealing with all kinds of stuff like
this so there are two two issues here
number
one people think that when they come up
with a single instance of a quote
violation of what you're saying that
invalidates what you said at the
population level so let's take a
specific example it is absolutely
incontestable that men are bigger than
women they're taller than women they're
physically bigger but yet you told me
earlier that you're a tall woman and
probably you're taller than me so the
fact that Pearl is taller than God does
not inv validate the statement that men
are taller than women so for example
every single player in the WNBA and the
women's NBA is taller than most men that
says nothing about the fact that men are
taller than women because that statement
holds at the population level so another
example humans are a sexually
reproducing species even though nuns and
Priests take a
celibacy vow the fact that some people
are celibate or asexual doesn't mean
that we're not a sexually reproducing
species humans are a sexually
reproducing species even though there
are people who are strictly homosexual
in their sexual part uh preferences so
so that the mindset the cognitive trap
that these people fall into is they
think that a singular quote violation of
a statement that holds true at the
population level violates the statement
at the population level so that's number
one the second point is and again I hope
for your viewers they don't mind that
I'm getting a bit professorial here but
uh Evolution recognizes that people have
the capacity for what's called
plasticity meaning that if I'm in an
environment a I do X but if I'm in
environment y I do something else so
example that I mentioned earlier with
the hza tribe
men's preferences are set at a
particular hourglass figure waste to hip
ratio but then it could be shifted to
the right or it could be shifted to the
left depending on
specific ecological conditions so if I
am in a culture where there is huge
famine that recurs then I will shift my
preferences to prefer heavier people
because heavier people correlates
status so all of theu that they tell you
oh but I know a tribe in Africa and I
know a tribe in Japan doesn't in any way
disproved the statement they're just
imbeciles so I'm curious does the media
affect sexual preferences at all no no
so think of it this way uh but by the
way this this is exactly the tension
remember earlier when I was uh mouthing
off all of the parasitic ideas in my
previous book one of them I talked about
I mentioned it quickly social
constructivism social constructivism is
the idea that human minds are born
tabula Raza empty slates and it is
socialization that then teaches us what
to prefer right so if only I hadn't
learned from Oprah and L magazine that I
should prefer women that look like
Beyonce right now Pearl I would be
trying to mate with my lawnmower but
it's only because Beyond because Oprah
taught me through media images that I
should like Beyonce that that's why I
find it attractive of course I'm being
factious because it's a ridiculous
argument humans are not born tabula
humans are born with biological
imperatives that have been selected
through millions of years of evolution
so I'll give you how would you prove
that so let's suppose I want to prove to
you that facial symmetry which is a a
measure of beauty what if I say that
this person is beautiful it typically
means that they have facial symmetry
well if I wanted to prove to you so you
might come and say oh but the reason why
you prefer facially symmetric faces is
because you learned that in the media
well actually it's the exact opposite
the media puts facially symmetric people
because it caters to my preferences well
how would I prove that to you well I
could take children who are too young to
have been socialized in other words by
definition I'm taking children who
haven't yet reached the cognitive
developmental stage to be socialized by
media images and I can show you that
they already exhibit the preference
towards facial symmetry so that
completely negates the idea that it's
due to Media or to my parents or to
advertising or to Oprah right we are
endowed with certain biological
preferences that come when we come to
Earth we already are equipped with those
preferences so no it's not the media
that taught me to want to mate with
Beyonce um do you so you mentioned
earlier in the interview that there are
like and I I you said it a little
differently but it was something along
the lines of like there's things we've
been evolved to like do but in modern
society or in 2023 we're not doing them
yeah could you explain that more sure so
the classic example would be in uh in
health or in medicine so this is so the
the theory is called the mismatch
hypothesis so think about your gustatory
preferences your taste buds so you and I
Pearl and probably every single person
who who watch this chat have evolved
gustatory preferences for fatty food now
the fatty preference might vary across
people you may like chocolate mousse I
may like juicy steak but what is common
to to both of us is we both like some
fatty food more than raw celery now why
is that
because my gustatory preferences and
yours are an adaptation to an
evolutionary environment in our past
that was defined by caloric scarcity and
caloric uncertainty meaning just like
for most for all other animals human
beings faced two recurring problems find
dinner and don't become someone's dinner
right you don't want to be prayed on by
this
sabertooth tiger and you don't you you
don't want to starve to death right well
then it makes perfect sense that we've
evolved the desire to hoard a lot of
food Gorge a lot of food and to do so in
preferring fatty High caloric foods to
less fatty foods now that preference is
perfectly adaptive in the environment of
our ancestral past where it there was
caloric scarcity and caloric uncertainty
but now here comes the
mismatch you live in London there isn't
caloric scarcity and caloric uncertainty
the only uncertainty is how long will
the traffic be before I get to eat my
three Big Mac that's the only
uncertainty you have right therefore my
taste buds which used to be perfectly
adaptive in the in our environmental
past becomes maladaptive today what and
how do I know that because if you look
at the top health Killers by the World
Health Organization all of them are
related to this mismatch
diabetes heart disease colon cancer high
blood pressure those are all diseases
their lifestyle diseases if you go to
hunter gatherer societies that are not
living in a modern environment you don't
typically see those diseases because
they are mimicking the environment of
our evolutionary past does that make
sense do you follow yeah yeah so like
like um how the Amish have like no can
wasn't there a study recently that said
the Amish have like no cancer I I
haven't seen that study but that that
might make sense in that first of all
they're they're doing a lot of work
right so just think about the amount of
caloric expenditure that they're
involved in just to do the daily things
that you take for granted right you just
walk three meters and stuff your face
with two Big Macs well they have to I
don't mean literally you I mean
prototypical
hey I like a Big Mac you know what I
mean okay fair enough fair enough fair
enough uh whereas you know they have to
really toil with the land and and exert
a lot of effort yeah so even if they're
eating fatty foods if they've spent
7,000 calories that day working in order
to get that food then they're probably
not going to have high blood pressure so
I don't know of that study that you
mentioned but I wouldn't be surprised
that it exists so does that mean will we
adapt like further in the future then so
will we start craving different types of
food or something yeah that's a great
question so it depends if the the
environment remains stable enough to
engender such an adaptation right so
different
traits require a different amount of
time for you to evolve that trait you
follow what I'm saying so example right
now I have 10 I just I don't know why I
just took off my wedding ring let me put
it back before before my wife divorc
okay so I have 10 I have 10 fingers you
have 10 fingers it is not this is called
a fixed trait meaning that it's not a
normal distribution it's not some of us
are born with 12 but some of us are as a
matter of fact when a baby's born the
first thing that the nurse will do is
count the number of toes and fingers
because if they don't have the fixed
number of 10 then there's a con
congenital genetic problem so if we now
were to say if you were to ask me well
could there be a selection environment
that would cause us to evolve an extra
finger well I would say theoretically
speaking that's possible but it would
take an extraordinarily longer time
period for us to evolve these types of
fixed traits away you get it so for
example a mole rat which lives
underground it never sees the sun of the
light of day actually through Evolution
it's evolved its eyes away it it no
longer has sight its ancestors had
eyesight but now it no longer needs eyes
and so now they are born without the
capacity to see on the other hand here
is a trait that can be selected in just
a few hundred years so for example the
genes that allow for you to be able to
process lactose
it doesn't take long for it to happen so
so for so for example cultures that have
pastoral living pastoral living means
you're raising livestock well cultures
that have that
practice typically have a gene that
allows them to process milk animal milk
precisely because they have the
environment that allows them to uh
evolve that Gene cultures that don't
have pastoral living where they don't
raise you know uh goats and cows and so
on they don't they typically have a much
greater rate of a gene that creates
lactose intolerance now that whether you
have the gene for processing lactose or
for not processing lactose that that
takes in the order of a couple hundred
years and you can get it but having a
third eye or a second heart or a 11th
finger that would take millions of years
so is that why there so much dispute in
like the nutrition Community like
because I mean I see like a new diet
every other day it's like I met someone
that was on like carnivore that's the
new thing now um Yes actually one of
those people is is a good friend of mine
and a high-profile guy you probably know
of him Jordan Peterson yeah uh he's on
the sup I mean and we've gone out many
times for for for dinner uh well not
many times but several times uh and
that's all he orders he'll order just a
massive steak not I mean literally
nothing else although we recently had
dinner together in in Budapest Hungary
and he introduced Big shrimps into his
diet and so I looked at him I said what
Jordan what you're eating something
other than steak uh look uh I think the
the nutrition uh stuff that you're
talking about actually comes from a lack
of adherence to the scientific method
right so you also see that by the way in
in mental health therapies where someone
comes along and they're a self ascribed
or self-defined Guru or life coach or
nutrition coach or coach and
they just espouse nonsense and
unfortunately most people who consume
information don't do the homework to to
gauge whether whatever that person is
pedling has actually gone through the
rigor of scientific testing right but
the reality is and I could tell you I
know you didn't ask this question but
since you're asking about nutrition I I
lost a I used to be historically very
thin I used to be a soccer player and
you know I was a runner and then over
the years once I didn't exercise as much
I progressively put on a lot of weight
so that you know 20 30 years later I was
much much heavier and I've since lost it
all and there really is no magic pill
and so for your audience who are
struggling to lose weight here are the
secrets you ready Pearl uh can I guess
go ahead can I guess
please is it eat less and exercise
more ding ding ding ding ding my God who
could have ever Envision this but you're
exactly right thank you yes thank you
doctor but but but there are specific
elements to what you just said so let me
just fill in the details okay so I I
basically if you say eat less it is
sufficiently vague that it might be
difficult to implement right but if I
say given my size my height and weight
and age for me to predictably lose a
pound and a half a week I need to eat
between 15 to 1,700 calories a day well
then if I do meet those goals there is
absolutely no way that I won't lose
weight now the problem comes precisely
because you said well you know I'll eat
less now we'll go to the restaurant and
I'll order a salad now the salad will be
a Caesar salad well unbeknownst to most
people the Caesar salad has 3,000
calories because of the cream that it
has in it so I'm wrongly thinking that
I'm eating healthily because I'm eating
a salad whereas in reality I'm gaining
weight eating the salad so number one be
so mad oh
wow you'd be mad if you ate a salad and
G yeah I don't even like salads then
you're gaining weight off of the salad
exactly so number one uh and here I got
a lot of help from my wife because she
would she still till today she enters
every single morsel of food that goes
into my mouth is entered into an app so
that at the end of the day I'm
accountable it's I didn't just say what
Pearl said eat less that's that's vague
who knows what that means eat less but
if if my wife can say hey you're at
1645 calories I'm seeing you itching to
get to the kitchen don't sit your ass
down well then I'm accountable to that
metric right so number one find out what
your basil caloric rate is if you know
if you're a a football linebacker and
you're 27 it might be 3,000 calories
right and then try to eat at least 500
calories fewer than what your base would
be base would be if I ate that much my
weight wouldn't change
so in my case 15 to 1700 calories every
day secondly I do 15 to 20,000 steps a
day no matter what I could have a very
busy day I could be teaching two classes
I could be working on a book I could be
doing pearls podcast it doesn't matter
by the end of that day I have to have
reached at least 15,000 steps guess what
do those two things and at the end of 18
months I ended up losing 80 six total
pounds
wow you lost 86 pounds from my heaviest
to my thinnest so now I'm a bit more
than my thinnest I'm about eight nine
pounds more than the lowest I got right
but at my heaviest known weight I mean I
my weight was that of a middle
linebacker in football but I was giving
up about 6 in on that middle linebacker
so I was you know well overweight uh and
so yeah now I'm back to the right weight
and you said you wrote about that in
your book yeah yeah so I wrote about it
in the happiness book in the chapter
where I was discussing uh you know the
importance of persistence and the
antifragility of failure uh so in that
context I was talking about that most
important goals that we set in our lives
you have to typically have grit stick to
itness persistence and the antifragility
of failure refers to the fact that you
can't let a failure completely break you
and make you brittle right so and hence
that's why the term antifragile right so
for
example uh if you look at most of the
top people in in most Fields so you know
JK Rowling had been rejected by every
single publisher until the last one that
didn't reject her that the one who wrote
Harry Potter stuff lonel Messi whom off
off before we started the show turns out
that you're the only person in the world
who's never heard of him Leonel Messi is
the greatest soccer player ever he was
told when he was a kid he's he's too
small to even make it as a professional
soccer player he turns out to be the
greatest soccer player ever Michael
Jordan the greatest basketball player
ever was told was not told was uh cut
from his sophomore high school team so
imagine there was a coach in his high
school that said sorry Michael you're
not good enough to make the team he ends
up becoming the greatest basketball
player uh Steven Spielberg the Great
American filmmaker was rejected not once
not twice but three times from USC's
film school so very few things that
you're going to do in life are not going
to be Laden with some minefields with
some failures and of course as the
cliche goes the the winner is the one
who gets back on the proverbial horse so
why did I talk about this in the context
of weight loss well because it takes an
incredible amount of grit and discipline
to lose 86 pounds because I am a human
being that has the gustatory preferences
to want to go to McDonald's and to get
the juicy burger and the chocolate
mousse but every single minute of every
single day I had a bifurcation I had one
of two choices I could make I could
stick to it or I could say well you know
if today I cheat and I just well come on
I tomorrow I can do it and that's why
it's almost impossible to lose weight by
the way it's only about 5% of people who
go on a diet that end up losing the
weight and keeping it off so it's almost
a a a sure losing proposition so the
only way you could do it is that if
you're
pathological in your discipline and
grittiness right you just have to stick
to it and I promise you if you stick to
it you will lose weight people have
heard me say this I I get stopped on the
street someone says guess what I did
exactly what you said and I'm now 42
pounds down and so there is no magic
it's very easy to understand it but it's
very tough to stick to it and your point
is more about the mindset of sticking to
something even through failure and that
eventually you will get it exactly right
look how about this writing a book I get
millions of people I mean tons of people
who write to me and say you know I'm an
aspiring author what what what's your
secret right well of course there are
there are elements that are difficult to
to teach right I mean some of us are
good writers some of us are not some of
us are good storytellers and we have a
comp compelling way of communicating
others don't now that's hard to teach
but there's an element to writing that's
exactly to the point of what we're
talking about which is every single day
rain or shine whether you're feeling
sick or not whether your kids are
annoying you or not whether you have a
million students writing to you or not
you have to complete a certain number of
words a day you're never going to be
able to submit your manuscript to your
publisher on time if you don't have the
grit to wake up every day and say I have
to hit 500 words today so a a a central
element of being a successful author is
just sticking to it right so you know
many many days I felt you know I I just
came back I just lectured a three-hour
class on a exhausted now I've got to
help the kids with some math assignment
oh God I don't I don't want to write
today but if I do that today tomorrow
too I'm going to be busy and the next
and oh look now I'm one week behind in
my writing schedule so nothing that you
do that's
meaningful uh you'll ever be able to do
without that Focus so in a way you're
it's interesting CU you said you didn't
write the second book with like when you
wrote the last book The parasitic mind
you didn't write you didn't expect
happiness to be the next book but it's
interesting cuz they almost go together
cuz it's like you kind of are
identifying like the problems like we go
to school like people in my age group
anyway like I would say we a lot of us
went to school and got this woke stuff
shoved Downs down our throats and it's
kind of been shoved down our throats
since we were like I mean I went to
Catholic school so it was a little
better but I have friends that had that
stuff like when we were like 12 13 years
old they're being told like gender
Theory um and then it's almost like your
the happiness book is almost like a like
a solution after you get rid of the
virus exactly you're that's perfectly
stated because I've actually exactly
argued that which is in a sense this
completes the story The the parasitic
mind was about how Minds can go you know
astray and then what are some positive
mindsets that I can adopt so I can lead
a happy fulfilled purposeful life and so
yes it completes the circle you're
exactly right go ahead go ahead no no go
ahead so yes I was just going to ask
what you just said like so what are the
best ways to do that you have to have
grit yes so grit uh so that's toward
towards the end of the book I talk about
that and early in the book I talk about
I can sort of go through some of the key
points uh early in the book I talk about
the two decisions that you'll make in
your life that are most likely to be the
ones that either impart great happiness
to you or regrettably great misery if
you don't make the right can I guess can
I guess please can I guess you didn't
read the book yet you're not cheating no
no I haven't read it no I haven't but
you're going to correct that by buying
it and reading I'm gonna be reading it
immediately it's like tonight you know
okay um number one has to
be uh you're the person you
marry yes and two two has to be
maybe it's either career or kids but I'm
guessing the kids would go with the
person you marry so I'm going to guess
maybe career see that explains why
you've got one 1.8 million followers on
on YouTube because you're a born
psychologist uh that's you you got it
exactly right well done Professor sad
gives you a 100 on the exam yes uh no
yeah you're exactly right so choosing
the right partner and choosing the right
profession are the two and again first
let me kind of in a in a in a simple way
explain why that's true and then I'll
I'll drill down what are some things
that I could look for in my job or my
spouse if I wake up next to a person
every day and I do one of these two
things I wake up next to them I go oh
God not this one again that's probably
not a ticket to happiness if I wake up
to this one I go yes my God I'm a lucky
person to be waking up next to this one
what did I do to deserve that right well
then you're certainly on your way to
starting off on the right side of the
bed now if I go off to work and that
process brings me great existential Glee
I'm kind of rubbing my hands I'm excited
at the the looming Day that's coming
because I've got all kinds of exciting
things happening well that's great and
then if I return to that person that I
was excited to wake up to in the morning
well I just cracked the secret to
happiness right but now of course the
devil is in the details what are some
things that I can do to maximize the
chances of picking the right spouse and
the right wife the right job the I
explained in the book that uh I'm humble
enough to say that I can't guarantee you
happiness but life is about statistical
probabilities so by implementing these
things you simply increase your chances
to happiness right in the same way that
if you want to decrease your chance to
have lung cancer don't smoke that
doesn't mean that non-smokers don't get
lung cancer but you certainly reduce
your chances by not smoking okay so
let's do choosing the right spouse first
so in evolutionary psychology there are
two opposing maxims or adages there is
the birds of a feather flock together
Maxim and the Opposites Attract do you
want to guess which is the one that's
most likely to guarantee long-term
success of a marriage um birds of a
feather flock to get because isn't it
when like the religion is the same the
like there's like three things that I
know when they're the same it's you're a
lot less likely to divorce you're
exactly right so it is birds of a
feather flock together now look if it's
for shortterm mating right I'm I'm just
looking for a you know a diance behind
the bushes then Opposites Attract might
actually be very nice I may be sexually
uh reserved and I might be an introvert
you might be sexually adventurous and an
extrovert and that complimentarity might
actually make for a better encounter so
for short-term ating we can certainly
propose that opposites ATT track can
work for long-term meeting exactly to
your point we have to assort in other
words birds of a feather flock together
on which which feathers well it's on
belief systems on life goals on
fundamental values which in part of
course could come from religion if I am
deeply committed to my faith and you are
a outspoken atheist it doesn't guarantee
that we're going to divorce but it's
we're certainly starting off on the
wrong foot because I'm I'm centered in
my faith and you despise all faith-based
things we we have a big mountain to
climb and so choosing someone with whom
you assort on these fundamental values
greatly increases your chances of a
long-term union now it sounds obvious
but yet of course we know that countless
marriages fail precis in part because
those they don't think about that right
because they think that that
original chemical attraction is going to
car you through now that doesn't mean
that 20 years into our marriage we can't
still be sexually attracted to each
other but it's certainly not going to
have the same butterflies that we had
that first three times that we were
right so there has to be something
fundamentally more than the fact that I
find you very attractive and vice versa
and we have fun together there has to be
this matching of the foundational values
that defines who we are so that's so
that's for spouse for someone that's not
religious what would that
be well it could be for example
uh sticking still within the the
religious realm I could be very
spiritual without being religious right
so for example you and I are having a
conversation right now it's a form of a
intellectual tangle that itself could be
a very spiritual experience right so if
I am someone who's very cynical whereas
you're someone who's very optimistic
well that that's such a foundational
difference in how we view the world I
right I wake up and and people are suck
and the world sucks and everything is
dark and we should die soon and who
cares about anything you wake up every
day and you know you're seeing flowers
floating it it's that difference between
us is probably going to weigh heavily in
our marriage so so it there are many
many ways Beyond religion by which we
can either match or or unmatch right
does that make sense yeah so it's like
being an optimist or a pessimist um
maybe what maybe like extroversion and
introversion I'd imagine that too or so
there's I'll come back in a second to
professions but uh in one of the later
chapters I talk about one of the other
secrets to you know to happiness I talk
I have a chapter titled Life as a
playground and I basically argue that
the the innate need to play is something
that is fundamental to human nature and
it's something that we shouldn't
perceive as growing out of right in the
same way that typically people have baby
teeth and then those baby teeth drop and
then your permanent adult teeths come in
well people think that CL is like your
baby teeth you play until a certain age
but then adult hits adulthood hits and
you should be serious nothing could be
further from the truth one of the
reasons I think that you know I've
resonated with many people is because
even though yes I'm a professor I have a
lot of knowledge and so on but I also
don't take myself seriously I joke
around I have all these sarcastic skits
and humorous skits I make fun of myself
right life is fun life is playful so to
the point about birds of a feather flock
together it and actually I cite some
research that exactly demonstrates this
people who are in a successful marriage
typically assort on how they score on
adult playfulness right so if I am
someone very playful very irreverent
you're someone who's very D and Sullen
it's not going to work bro I never even
thought about that that's so interesting
oh thanks how do you how do they measure
adult playfulness like how long do you
how many hours you play board games a
week or what no no it's it's a very good
question it's the way you do that
actually is the way you measure all
types of psychological traits so there
is a formal procedure by which I can
develop a what's called a psychometric
scale which is usually a scale it's a
survey it's a questionnaire that's
typically made up of a statement but
many of those which you answer let's say
strongly disagree to strongly agree then
when I add up all those scores I can map
you on the Continuum for that trait
right so I could apply it for dogmatism
or assertiveness or stick to itness or
jealousy right I mean right when you're
measuring someone's weight there is a
scale that I use to measure your weight
your your 142 pounds right well the same
process applies
for something like a psychological trait
I have to develop a validated scale to
measure you on that trait and so adult
playfulness is not measured as you said
by Behavior how often do you play uh
board games it's actually a bunch of
items which you know you answer I tally
those scores and then I could say oh you
know Pearl scores in the 93rd percentile
of playfulness whereas you get it yeah
like I took the a couple years ago the
understand myself thing are you talk
about that one I like Jordan Peterson's
test is that kind of similar oh yeah
exactly so all all those tests that he
he he puts on his website whatever they
exactly stem from what's called
personality psychology testing where you
you have to find psychometric scales
that measure each of the components of
your personality right one of them might
be understanding yourself it could be I
mean there's a million as a matter of
fact the name of the website I think
that's what I meant is that's what
that's that's the website name yeah or I
think I I don't remember what the name
is but uh but but but there are
literally I think I well I mentioned
this in one of the early chapters of the
happiness book uh some psychologists uh
I think it was maybe in the
1930s they first listed all of the
words in the DI the English dictionary
that c capture some element of one's
personality inquisitiveness
impulsiveness dogmatism uh uh
risk-taking whatever and I think the
first pass was something like
18,000 different traits but then they
they distilled them to a fewer so for
example now you probably have heard of
The Big Five personality test right the
big five is basically arguing that on
for most people you can capture
differences across people on these five
fundamental factors right so all other
things equal if you're going to match up
with someone it'll be good if you have
probably similar personalities on some
of these fundamental values should we go
to profession next yeah yeah but so I
just want to make sure I understand so I
basically or someone's going to get
married you want to be the personalities
to be like
similar
so personalities is not the most most
important one for birds of a feather
flock together the most important one is
what you mentioned earlier things
related to values belief systems
religion because for personalities it's
the story is a bit more complex because
as I mentioned earlier there are some
complimentarity in personalities that
might often work I'm someone who is very
much uh you know reserved you're someone
who and that might actually serve me
well if I'm with someone extroverted so
so it doesn't apply for all personality
traits the the birds of a feather flock
together is largely for Value based
systems belief systems religion so on
okay by the way another one is height
which is not so much you know a a value
system or but it's very very rare for
men and women to go together if the
woman is taller than the
man so much so that there was a
scientific study done uh I don't I don't
have what else are we supposed to do
we're just up here I know that's why you
said ear how but do you mind if I ask
how tall you are no I'm six foot but I
have friends that are 63
65 yeah well see that's a big big
problem so I always say that the two
killers for women's mating prospects is
their height no and their education
level
because so if you are tall and you're a
PhD good luck I mean as a woman why
because
women hold on hold on it's not so much
that women want a guy to be over some
minimal height because if that were the
case then most men would be sitting
celibate twiddling their thumbs what's
important is that the a man be taller
than some prospective woman right so uh
you know uh lonel Messi to go back to
him is not a tall guy but he's lonel
Messi so he can compensate literally for
his shorter stature by being a great
athlete someone can be smart someone
could be charming someone could be sexy
so there are many ways that I can
compensate for not being tall but if I'm
a tall woman and I absolutely don't want
to be with a guy who's shorter than me
well statistically speaking the taller
that I am they are just a smaller pool
of men to choose from if I'm 6'2 and I'm
a woman I I'm looking for guys who are
6'3 and more not that they don't exist
but there's just fewer of them now if
I'm 6'2 I'm a woman and I'm a PhD I also
don't want to be with a guy who's lesser
status than me right so now I need a
super tall guy who is a PhD in neuro
Anatomy from Stanford now I'm screwed
now I'm gonna be very miserable with my
cats it'd be like the Kevin Samuels the
bile dog you know have you seen that
what is that I don't know that reference
you don't know Kevin Samuels
who's that what this is like you're
surprised I don't know Kevin Samuels
coming from the woman who doesn't know
lonel Messi all right I'm a woman we
don't watch sports we don't even I I
play sports and women we don't even
watch our own sports like like but am I
right about the height thing would you
would you date a guy who's shorter than
you a little bit yeah I wouldn't go like
a ton but I mean I feel like it's kind
of like what choice do you have you know
what I mean it's like you're
outrageously tall like you know there's
only so many things you can like ask for
I think anyways but I have a friend
she's 6'5 she married a guy that was 610
don't know how they found each other
don't know how don't know how it
happened but but but by the way just to
finish the point about the study uh it
was a study done with I think it was if
I I hope I'm not getting the numbers
wrong I think it was they looked at
720 you know naturally occurring couples
like actual couples
guess how many of the
720 the woman was taller than the guy
okay let me guess I'm going to guess
it's a really small percentage
because I know all I I know so many of
the tallest women and they always seem
to marry taller men I don't know where
that we we find them but we just do um
so I'm G to say
5% it's way less than that it was one
out of 72 no way so 719 if I'm getting
my numbers right anyways the bottom line
is that it's unbelievably and often
times when my wife and I will be walking
and I notice what looks like a violation
I go look look that's that's the one guy
that's the one couple where they violate
because it's so unlikely to to see so
again on a on physical traits the number
one assortative Q is height by the way
there is one trait where we specifically
choose someone who is most different
from us do you want to guess what that
one now if you if you get this one right
I might have to give you the A+ on the
exam okay I think it's going to be women
like men that are more disagreeable than
them so I don't know if that's true but
that's I thought I would get it I was so
confident it's actually it's it's a
physical thing oh a physical it's not a
it's not a trait and by well I'll give
you another hint it's not physical in
the sense that it's a it's a trait that
you see that should give you a big hint
but I'm not going to give you an A+
because I've given you a lot of hints
now okay it's something you see it's not
something you see so that should be a
big H wait I'm I'm sorry I need to it's
a physical trait that you don't
see it's a it's a physical reality That
You Don't See
yes I don't think I'm going to get this
one what I'm think I'm thinking muscle
like men don't like muscular no but you
could see those you could see those okay
you ready yeah it's smell
oh yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't have
guessed that I I've heard that before
but I wouldn't have guessed it so let me
let me break it down for you so there's
something called the major hytto
compatibility complex which is a set of
genes that captures each of our unique
immunological profiles now that IM
logical profile is in part coded in my
unique smell so that you may smell me
Pearl and say oh I really like God smell
another woman might smell me and she may
not find my smell as attractive what
determines whether you find my smell
uniquely attractive or not is how
dissimilar my MHC is to yours the more
our major hytto compatibility complex
genes are dissimilar from each other the
more we will find each other's smell to
be uniquely intoxicating now why is that
because when you are attracted to the
smell of someone who is immunologically
as different as possible from you that
grants greater insurance coverage for
your children in other words they have
greater immunological defense systems by
so think about it in the extreme case
that's why incest is a taboo because
when you are mating with your brother or
sister or with your father or mother
then you are you're doing exactly the
opposite of what I just said right so
and and there is research that shows
that uh when you take the t-shirts that
people wear put them in a in a in a
plastic bag then you so this was done
with men's shirts they wear a white
T-shirt then you put it in a bag then
women come and they smell the shirt
it all assorts in exactly the way that I
just said so this proves to you again I
mean not you specifically but to people
listening that when people think oh but
you know humans are not animals we're
cultural beings humans are as
animalistic as any other animal okay so
does that
mean okay I'm gonna phrase this the
right way so excuse me but okay so if I
have a smell does the person with a
different smell than
me like what causes like I know you like
would we CU like wouldn't cuz PE you
know have you seen that okay have you
seen that thing on I I don't you
probably haven't but have you seen that
thing that it's like sisters or or
brother and sister or
dating no different world okay um
basically there's like um Instagram
accounts where they guess if people are
siblings or they're dating and I the
point is that people tend I I think
people tend to choose partners that kind
of look like themselves for whatever
reason but I would think that people
with more similar genetic makeups which
I'm imagining if they look like each
other probably a similar like both Irish
both German whatever um like wouldn't
the smell be the same then so so you're
saying that the whatever experiment
you're talking about or whatever
Instagram people who are dating tend to
look more more alike than people who are
not dating is that is that the yeah yeah
so I I'm not sure about that although
that could be because you might be
wanting to date someone that's within
your
ingroup uh but still not your brother or
sister right so for example right so so
you know if I'm a if I'm Chinese there
might be some cultural expectations that
I marry someone who is racially or
ethnically
Chinese but there's a lot of people to
choose from so on average if I'm Chinese
and I marry a Chinese woman we're going
to have more traits that are similar
than if I were to marry Pearl so I think
that's how that mechanism worked but the
other one about the smell it's that the
same smell so I exude the smell that I
exude no matter what two different women
will evaluate that same smell
differently as a function of what their
immunological profile is right so Pearl
smells me and goes oh my God you smell
so good Janet smells me and says yeah
average so nothing's changed right my
smell has remained the same but it
either matches up well with you and it
doesn't match as well with Janet and in
this case match up means be as
dissimilar as possible are is that cuz
are we smelling for like certain
traits no we're we're actually literally
smelling that major hytto compatibility
complex which is if you like it's the
it's the all Factory signature of my
immune system right okay by the way
there's actually other studies which is
kind of relevant in marketing which so I
one of the things that I teach is
consumer psychology
uh my preference for a
perfume depends on my major
histo compatibility complex you
understand what I mean so for example
I'll take one perfume the and I will put
it on me and smell it on me and I will
put it on someone else and smell it on
them now you would think that perfume is
the same smell so I should find it
either as attractive smelling or
unattractive smelling irrespective of
whom I put it on but that's not true if
I put it on me and I smell it I go wow
that really that fits me it smells nice
on me whereas I put it on someone else I
go yeah I don't like it and that itself
the preference for perfumes turns out to
be a matching process to my immune
system you
follow half I as best as I Think I Can
Am I blowing your mind no well okay I've
heard the smell thing I just don't
understand like what like what we're
smelling like because I'd imagine
there's some Evolution or like you're
looking for you're smelling my immune
system so like okay so I smell that
someone gets colds more or like less
well I mean not at that level you're not
SM like right it's it's not coding oh
I'm smelling this person is more prone
to pneumonia right it's just it's just
an affective response right I smell this
I go that smells nice I smell this that
doesn't smell nice why did my brain code
this as smelling good or not smelling
good what I'm saying to you is what the
research has found is that that
preference that I experience is actually
but think of it another way don't dogs
go around smelling every single what are
they doing are they consciously saying
oh this dog I want to meet with because
she's less likely to have bronchitis no
but there is a signature that's being
communicated through that smell all I'm
saying is that humans have that ability
so it's basically you got to find
someone where the guy is taller they
like each other's smell and they have
the same values and boom married for
life and and a and a big penis of course
oh god um I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding um okay so then you got to pick
your
career yes let's do that one that's
great uh so there I basically argue that
they are two things if possible now I
understand that not everybody will be
able to instantiate these things and
there are solutions for that but if you
hit the the lottery in terms of
occupations these are the two things you
want to be looking for number one I
argue that any profession that allows
you to instantiate your creative impulse
is one that's going to give you purpose
and meaning but that could be many
things artists standup Comics podcasters
professor
authors uh filmmakers Architects chefs
each of these professions is completely
different right but what do they share
in common they're creating something
which here to for had been not created
right the chef creates a plate that he
put together and then there's this magic
culinary experience the architecte
creates a new structure the standup
comic creates a new set of jokes that
are going to be consumed that night's
show the the the author writes a book
that 18 months earlier there wasn't a
single syllable written 18 months later
people are reading it on the beach in
Dubai so anything that allows me to
immerse myself in the magical process of
creation it is going to all other things
equal give me a lot of purpose and
meaning and so in my case remember I
said earlier you know if you wake up
next to a person that you love then you
go off to a job I'm I'm always happy
when I'm most of the time I'm happy when
I'm in my job I I don't I say most
because I I'm not really keen on the
administrative stuff of being a
professor but whenever I'm creating
whether I'm creating new content online
creating a new lecture create creating
new scientific knowledge creating a new
book all of these things give me such
sense of purpose and meaning because I
know that hopefully someone is going to
consume this and it's going to matter to
them and I'm I'm enriched by knowing
that that's a small contribution I can
make so number one anything that allows
me to create is going to lead to
happiness the second thing is anything
that allows me temporal freedom in my
job now what does that mean contrast how
I live my life which is I work very long
hours but I'm floating right to now
after this show I could go off to the
cafe with my laptop and start thinking
about what should be the top three book
ideas for my next book then I could come
back home I could work on something else
that so I'm always kind of nibbling at
different things floating around I don't
have a set schedule most days I mean yes
of course I've got media appearances and
departmental meetings and lectures to
teach but otherwise I could pursue
anything I'm interested in at any time I
could get up at 2: in the morning and
work on my next book because I know I
can wake up later that day because I
don't have anything at 8:00 next morning
now compare that with say a factory
worker where even their bathroom breaks
are mandated by the Union at at 10 at
10:15 you get a 5 minute bathroom break
at 12 to 12:20 you get lunch at 5 you
right so that temporal lack of Freedom
uh I call it scheduling asfixia you're
re you're literally choking me if if
I've got three four meetings in a day my
head explodes because I feel like I'm
being choked because I can't just float
around so if you can immerse yourself in
creativity and if you could do so with a
lot of time Freedom you've hit the
jackpot okay so if you're going to do
like a manual on how to be happy it
would basically be get what you what you
did in a way get get the the husband or
wife that you like the smell the guy's
taller and um the per they're more
similar to in values boom uh life live
life as a place
playground uh I also talk about uh one
of the chapters is solely reserved to
what I call the inverted U the inverted
U is something that the ancient Greeks
had already told us about specifically
Aristotle which he called the golden
mean so too little of something is not
good too much of something is not good
and The Sweet Spot is somewhere in the
middle now in the case of Aristotle he
used the example say of a soldier if a
soldier is truly cowardly not courageous
enough that's not good if he is so
courageous that he becomes a reckless
martyr he dies within 5 seconds in
battle that's not good so there is some
middle ground and so what I do in that
chapter is I demonstrate that this
inverted you too little not good too
much not good and the top is somewhere
in the middle I demonstrate that for a
bewildering number of cases in other
words I demonstrate that probably the
most important Universal key to maximal
flourishing and happiness is to always
find The Sweet Spot irrespective of what
you're doing so I'll just give you one
or two
examples what what is the intensity rate
at which you should exercise follows an
inverted you if if it's too if it's not
intense enough it's not good if it's too
intense it's not good there's a sweet
spot in the inverted U uh how
perfectionist you are follows an
inverted you so for example if you're an
author and you're not at all
perfectionist your work will suffer
because there'll be tons of Errors if
you are like me on the wrong side of the
curve but on the other end you're
maladaptively perfectionist I end up
spending 50,000 hours rereading my book
because God forbid there might be one
comma out of place well that's also
suboptimal right had I spent a bit less
time I could have been more productive
so like everything else perfectionism
lies with the inverted use so I
demonstrate in that chapter that for
everything for food for sex for for Life
Pursuits it's always following this
sweet spot curve because and it's almost
like when you look at people that are
and I'm just CU you're talking about it
the people that are obsessed with the
gem there's like a sweet spot where it's
like you know some people they live
their life and they have these
Tupperware things and they're like
weighing every single food they eat and
that just looks kind of like long for a
lifetime I'm like oh not couldn't be me
I don't I don't know um and but then you
have fat people on the other side so
you're saying it's kind of like a sweet
spot in between ex well exactly even
think about uh even the pursuit of
happiness follows a inverted you you
know if you don't willfully pursue it
enough of course you're going to be
miserable and so on if you are so dogged
in your pursuit to happiness that itself
can lead to unhappiness and actually
there's an important Point here in
towards the end of the book I use a
quote from Victor Frankle uh who was a
uh Holocaust Survivor who wrote a book
on you know the meaning of life and so
on and he talks about you know you you
should never willfully pursue success
success is something that is a
consequence of you making right
decisions and I argue that it's the
exact same process for happiness right
you I don't wake up in the morning and
say what are some things I can do today
to increase my happiness but rather if
I've made a set of good decisions in my
life if I have adopted a set of good
positive mindsets the outcome of that
will be that I will typically be happy
and just one other quick thing uh about
50% of our differences in happiness
scores comes from our genes okay so
really yeah right now so I may have a
sunny disposition you may have a less
Sunny disposition now that's simply due
to the my unique genetic combination and
your unique genetic combination but the
good news Pearl is that if 50% of your
happiness scores is inscribed in your
genes that means the other 50% is not
that means the other 50% is up for grab
so even though I may start off
Genetically speaking on a in a happier
Point than you do if I make wrong
decisions if I adopt poor mindsets I may
end up lower on the happiness totem than
you will because you've made better
decisions and so that's really the point
of the book to take you through a bunch
of these mindsets that statistically
speaking will increase your chances of
Happiness wow the jeans the you know I
used to always think everything was more
nature like rather than
nurture and the reason I thought that
was because I would look at single
mother home
stats um because I mean you kind of see
how messed up the kids turn out you're
like this is not good but what actually
switched my mind a little bit a couple
years ago it was like when I was 22 I
found out I had a brother that I didn't
know about um and he was from both of my
parents but they like so he's 100%
brother but they gave him up for
adoption because they were really young
and I didn't meet him until the boy was
like
30 um and he was actually so similar to
my family it was actually insane even
though like none of us had ever talked
to him wow yeah it was it was super
crazy because I had no idea who existed
like you couldn't have you are you in
touch with him today yeah I mean he'll
come to some stuff like occasionally CU
I'm one of 10 kids total if you include
him yeah I know yeah I know kind of
crazy story but wow I never I I
seriously never thought like genes
affected per like I always just kind of
was a DieHard like conservative where I
was kind of like it's the choices you
make in life and whatever and I know
there's some truth to that but that
experience kind of made me realize that
there's more variability than I had
thought before because he like walks
like my
brothers and he which is weird because
like again they've never even met like
he um I studied economics so did he he
um was a sales software engineer I used
to work in sales my dad's an engineer
it's kind of like amazing and he had he
had um a brother that was also adopted
in his family because his mom was like
Barren and that brother is like nothing
like him like he has more in common with
us yeah exactly well I can I can weigh
in on that you know scientifically
speaking so that the the whole nature
nurture debate of course is something
that arises often in evolutionary
psychology now this may or may not
surprise you the the nature nurture
debate in a sense is a false dichotomy
and let me here when I'm when I'm
explaining this to to my students uh one
of the ways that I found that they're
able to understand that point is by
using What's called the cake metaphor so
when you when you take a cake before you
bake it and you look at all of the
ingredients that are going to go to the
cake so there here are the eggs here's
the flour here's the sugar here's the
butter so the all each of the
ingredients are distinct and separate
from each other now I'm going to bake
the cake so now the final cake is made
if I now tell you can you please point
to the eggs in the cake can you please
point to the butter you're unable to now
you can see what's the analogy nature
and nurture we are an inextricable mix
of both of these right for very very few
traits is it only nature and for very
very few traits is it only nurture for
most traits it's some combination of
these but one final point on this issue
when it is due to nurture it that
doesn't usually mean it's not nature
because typically nurture exists in its
form because of nature do you follow
what I mean so meaning that for example
when I so when culture socialize women
to be more sexually prudent in their
sexual behavior than men right now you
could argue oh but that's not due to
biology that's BEC that's learning they
learned that through their culture but
that doesn't really explain anything
because the question then becomes why is
it that just coincidentally in every
single culture that's ever been studied
the pattern of socialization happens in
exactly that form it happens in that
form because socialization practices
exist to support nature so it's not
nature or nurture everything is nature
because yeah so because nurture it's
almost like Society like okay people
come together they make a society but
they make a lot of practices based on
the way nature is so yeah so it's like
the the boy like they always use the
toys or whatever but really they made
the toys is more like I'm guessing it's
like Legos cuz my brother loved Legos so
I'm guessing Legos are like boy toys but
like kind of makes sense cuz men are
more of the engineers they like to build
stuff so it's more to adapt can I give
you a slightly technical explanation of
specifically sex specific toy
preferences this is going to blow your
mind you ready yeah okay so there's
something so this is in chapter S of the
parasitic mind where I talk about the
chapters titled how to seek truth how
can I if if I'm sitting in front of a
hostile crowd and I want to try to
convince you that the position I'm
taking is the correct one what would be
the tools that I should use to convince
you of that and so here I talk you ready
can I guess okay humor humor no well you
could certainly do humor and I do use
that but but that's kind of a a delivery
style this is more cognitive based uh so
let's suppose I want to convince you the
reason why I thought about talking to
you about this because you said toys so
I want to prove to you that sex specific
toy preferences the fact that boys
prefer certain toys on average and girls
prefer certain other toys on average
that's not due to social
construction but it is biological and
Universal based right how would I go
about doing that and so here what I'm
going to do forgive me I'm just going to
use the fancy language and then I'll
explain it I'm going to build a
nomological network of cumulative
evidence to prove my point what does
that mean I'm going to get you data from
across societies from across time
periods from across animals from across
methodologies all of which point to the
veracity for the truth of my position so
let me demonstrate that so now remember
the point that I'm trying to make is
that no toy preferences are not due to
social social construction they're not
just arbitrarily learned okay so first I
can get you data from developmental
psychology where I can specifically
choose children who are too young to be
socialized just like the earlier example
I gave with facial symmetry I can get
you data from kids who are too young to
be socialized and I can show you that
little boys and little girls already
exhibit those toy preferences now that
just that finding is enough to kill the
social constructivist argument but I'm
not going to stop there because again
I'm going to build this entire network
of evidence that's going to drown you
with evidence okay number two how about
I get you data from veret monkeys reesus
monkeys and chimpanzees showing you that
our animal cousins their infants exhibit
the exact same sex specific toy
preferences that we do well now you're
in trouble if you're a social
constructivist because now you have to
explain why the parents of little veret
monkey and the parents of little Reese's
monkey are also part of the patriarchy
okay so now I've gotten new data from
developmental psychology I've gotten you
data from what's called comparative
psychology comparing across species now
I can get you data from cultures that
are completely different from the West I
can get you data from subsaharan nomadic
cultures in Africa showing you that they
exhibit the same sex specific toy
preferences now you might come back and
say okay sure but but that's all
contemporary data oh no problem I can
get you data from 2,500 years ago in
ancient Greece and ancient uh uh Roman
period where on ferary monuments on mums
where there are depictions of children
playing they're depicted playing with
the exact same sex specific toy
preferences that we have today I'll do
one more although the network is much
bigger one more bear with me I can get
you data from Pediatrics from medicine
for children showing you that little
girls who suffer from an
endocrinological disorder called
congenital adrenal hyperplasia when a
little girl suffers from that her
behavior becomes masculinized so little
girls who have that endocrinological
disorder exhibit toy preferences that
are exactly reversed they have the toy
preferences of little boys so look how
I'm getting you data across cultures
across time periods across species
across methodologies cross disciplines
all of which prove my point so one of
the reasons per while it's very hard to
quote cancel Gat s is because when I
take a position I've done my homework
I've built my nomological network so I
can go into the most hostile crowds full
of a wide range of imbecile and idiots
who are going to try to scream me down
but I have built the network so
therefore good luck to you if you want
to debate me so I think that's the way
that we try to get out of screaming past
each other I'll just present you the
evidence and hopefully you'll come to
the right conclusion so how do you
navigate that though with the fact that
now you get all these kind of
studies that come out and I'm not I'm
not going to you know I'm not going to
pretend I'm like an a crazy academic or
whatever but it's like you just kind of
like you were saying you just have this
natural reasoning where it's like
they'll they'll tell me oh I have the
study that the sky is not blue water is
not wet and I'm like you know what they
start to almost like make up studies
somehow and usually if I look into it
it's like a feminist studies professor
professor or something like that's kind
of like the way I do it as I'll look at
the department so that would be a that
would be a very good cue to use to
decide whether the study is valuable if
it if it says the name of the person and
then it says woman studies after then
just throw it in the dust bin of History
because I mean but look the reality is
that one of the so to our earlier point
about what's gone wrong in Academia the
problem of course it's not everywhere in
Academia but in many disciplines they
have conflated activism for the real
mission of an academic which is to seek
truth right whereas in many fields for
take for example sociology sociology is
not inherently unscientific right I mean
the pursuit of studying phenomena that
are sociological is perfectly within the
realm of of science right I mean what's
more important than studying how humans
navigate within social systems so that's
great the problem with sociology is that
it has been parasitized by ideology so a
sociologist is no longer a purveyor of
truth but rather he or she is an
activist trying to push a particular
agenda and that's a violation of the
scientific method so when you have
women's studies and peace studies and
studies and all these kinds of
words with studies then you your your
alarm Bell should go up because you know
that the people who are creating these
studies are typically driven by an
ideological agenda rather than the
unbiased pursuit of the truth yeah well
it almost seems like um because when I
was growing up Neil de grass like Tyson
was considered an expert in everything
and now I mean now I see him just like
kind of going off the rails I don't know
what so here you ready you ready you see
my glasses these are Gat sads glasses my
glasses are substantially higher IQ than
Neil the grass
Tyson I will put my glasses in an IQ
test against that lobotomized imbecile
and I guarantee that my glasses will get
a higher IQ score that proves to you you
that you you shouldn't think that
someone is smart because of that title
or listen to what they say when this
buffoon goes on the all the shows
arguing about you know gender whatever
all the he's doing now right by
the way have you Pearl have you seen the
clip where I transition from male to
female on my channel no no but I'm I'm
sure I'm why have you been living such
an impoverished life Ready's show me
show me your transition I didn't know
you could do that well I don't know I I
I'll have to I'll have to send you the
link and you could post it so what I did
basically because I use satire and
sarcasm and mockery and humor to make
some points Neil de grass Tyson had gone
on some show I can't remember which one
where he said what do you mean male or
female if today I'm wearing more makeup
and and and this I'm more female if
right so basically he was arguing that
whether I'm male or female is based on
you know what I wear and so on right
right and so I went on a on my channel I
opened up my laptop I took a bunch of
wigs that we had from Halloween and I
went I started off I said look right now
you're looking at the epitome of
masculinity right I'm 100% male Now
watch how I'm going to transition to
different percentages of female based on
and so I start putting one quarter
lipstick I wear different wigs and so
you can actually watch the whole clip as
I transition from
sexiest male alive to complete female
you're your your your viewers should not
be missing out on that
transition well yeah but if for people
that don't like follow it a lot of times
I guess it can be there's like obvious
ones but I'll give you an example like
someone came on my show and they were
saying that like women tend to be more
attracted to their husbands that like do
chores and I just knew
I mean it's
possible but I mean it just sounds like
feminist propag you know what I mean I
hear this I'm like what what like fat
chick made this study do you know what I
mean like like I'm like this is some
fatty that's like at her job and she's
just mad her husband isn't doing the
dishes didn't even well I mean you I
think you're right because if you by the
way you let's see if okay here's another
exam you ready what is the cultural
product that we can study to tell us the
most about female fantasies of the ideal
male okay I know I know I'm going to
guess it's got to be romance novels
right you don't have to say anything
else you got it it y 50 50 Shades and
I'm going to tell you why I came to this
conclusion because I interviewed male
only fans models I've interviewed over a
thousand people so some of the stuff
yeah some of this stuff is just because
I do the show so I have like panelists
in my apartment well the studio every
week and like I think we have over 800
guests logged and then we didn't even
log it the first six so I don't it's a
ton of people but you start to like
notice patterns and what I noticed was
two things okay one the women would AR
they would always flirt with after the
show the guy they argued the most with
so I don't know what like I don't know
what that tells you
but yeah and then the second thing I
noticed was the male only fans model
said I mean obviously some of them it's
more for guys but when they had like
female stuff and I also had a male
escort um that's like the number one
thing that they said women requested was
like the 50 Shade I don't know what they
call it like the BD whatever right yeah
but they they said that was like the
number one thing requested and it kind
of matched up with the fact that the 50
Shades of Gray like sold a bajillion
copies exactly so romance novels are
almost exclusively read by women so if
for example when I'm teaching a consumer
Behavior course I say well look people
who are in the business of creating
products that hopefully will sell a lot
inherently they understand human nature
right they may have not taken my course
in evolutionary psychology but they are
good marketers right because otherwise
the market would would would would give
them the feedback that don't care about
your PR and actually I'll I'll speak
exactly to that point as relating to
romance novels so romance novels are the
perfect uh medium from which to study
female sexuality is because the male
protagonist is the epitome of what women
want to fantasize about when they're
thinking about the ideal guy right so
he's got a six-pack he wrestles
alligators on a six fact but he wins he
is a prince and he's also a
neurosurgeon he he's very muscular and
fit he's very bold and aggressive but he
could only be tamed by the love of this
one good woman I just I just describe
sing do you know what I mean exactly us
that dream exactly uh so and and and it
turns out that that my wife gets to wake
up next to that dream every single day
but but anyways what a Lucky Gal he is
very lucky I I always try to remind her
of that she's not as convinced as we are
here but no but okay so so now there was
a company okay so I think your your
viewers are going to really appreciate
this I I don't remember the name of the
company or what you know the context was
but there was a company that apparently
had uh decided that they want to break
free of this you know toxic masculine
stereotype so they wanted to they wanted
to create exactly your laughter says it
all they wanted to create a a new
definition of masculinity you know the
guy is pear-shaped he's nasal voiced he
plays video games all day in his
basement he cries watching Bridget Jones
Diary he's very sensitive right so
because by the way here what they're
doing they're succumbing they meaning
the the progressive folks they're
succumbing to the tabula Raza premise
which is uh women are born empty minds
and it's the romance novel that's going
to teach them what they should be
attracted to to our earlier point right
no what do you think happened when they
released the progressive line of male
hero what do you think happened to the
sales oh they had to tank good luck of
course of course it failed and so so
easy just convince women we're amazing
special young forever and we deserve the
world you'll make so much money that's
all they had to
do exactly right and so so a good
marketer is one who ultimately
understands human nature I explained to
my MBA students you'll never be a good
marketer if your view of the world is
rooted in things that are violations of
human nature right the reason McDonald's
sells well it's not because they have
Justin Timberlake doing the Jingle I
mean that helps me remember McDonald's
but if McDonald's today decided we're no
longer selling fatty french fries and
fatty Burgers we're going to sell raw
grass juice no amount of advertising is
going to work because it doesn't
coincide with the preferences that my
taste buds have evolved to prefer right
so romance novels I need the sexy tall
muscular neurosurgeon that's what I'm
fantasizing about right H if you give me
the pear-shaped whiny boy that's never
going to trigger my juices do you know
what I just I reacted to this clip today
okay have you heard of Gray's
Anatomy it's a television show about the
Physicians and all that yeah yeah okay I
watched this video and it was like a
clip from it my sisters all watched this
growing up and it was a woman that was
like a maybe like five six kind of
average looking chick she is having two
guys that were probably like eights or
Nines in attractiveness fighting over
her I'm like really why are you selling
these
dreams like you're telling me these
30-some year old doctors are just dying
to dates this average chick I'm like
they just but I'm like us women we would
love that we're like yes yes and by the
way from the very little maybe I'll now
that we know each other maybe I'll I'll
dig deeper into your content I by the
way the only way I knew you by I knew
you is when I would do I recently
discovered the scrolling of the
Instagram yes I'm old and uh and I would
see you coming up on these different
shows where you're saying something and
then other people are getting upset and
so that's how I got to know who you are
and the reality is that usually the
things that you're saying are perfectly
consistent with what we expect in
evolutionary psychology but your message
is not hopeful you see and therefore it
triggers people so what's a nicer
message if I'm a five or six woman as
you said your ranking don't I want to
dream that there is a line an orderly
lineup of tens who want to date me
because you
know just
light exactly so so that's why
evolutionary psychology angers a lot of
people because people don't want to hear
that there are innate preferences that
we have right but but even if we have
innate preferences that doesn't mean
that we are doomed to to be miserable in
The Mating Market as I said earlier I
may not be tall but I can compensate for
that by having many other attributes
that are very desirable to women right
so the fact that I may not score well on
one attribute doesn't mean that I'm
doomed to a life of sexual frustration
so but to argue that no no no women
don't care about guys who are fit no no
no women don't prefer a guy who's six
foot rather than a guy who's five foot
is insane right it's it's go ahead well
because my question is
see I just if I had to predict it I
don't think people are going to get
together more in the next 20 30 years
so you know I think I I think like on an
individual level we can all be hopeful I
I think my future's bright I think your
Future's bright you know sounds amazing
but I'm like as a group do you really
think that people are going to get
together more in the next 50 years by
get together you mean like marriage
relation sense yeah like marriage
relationship and family I just don't see
anything that indicates it's going in
that direction well in a sense your your
intuition is certainly true and where I
live so in Quebec so I'm in Montreal
Quebec it it it's almost rare to see
quebecers getting married right so the
whole institution of marriage seems to
have completely skipped over Quebec of
course it doesn't apply to everyone but
and in a in in part Quebec is very much
of a quote feminist Society so Quebec is
I think the only place in North America
where when a a couple get married the
woman doesn't automatically by by by law
take the man's uh family name as a
matter of fact so for example my wife
and I are married everybody in our
family our children and and myself we
have my last name but my wife has her
maiden name and she can't say I I want
to have the same family name as my
husband because I want us to go to a
hotel and we all have the the same
family name I'm married to this guyy the
only way she could do it is she could be
hyphenated she could have her maiden
name hyen my name if she wanted to have
my name she'd have to do a legal change
of name which is a very long process so
there are strange things that happen
when a society becomes fully feminized
yeah so you know I hear this a lot that
I'm like I I say that like the what I
say is kind of Doom and Gloom but I'm
like I don't know what other usion you
guys want me to come to like I just
don't see any data that it's going going
the other way I'd like it to I'm from a
family at 10 it was amazing and all 10
are from the same parents H sort of it's
like um the one we gave up for adoption
there were six that might so seven are
like biological and three we adopted
later so it's kind of funny I've been on
both ends of adoption where we've
adopted and we we gave one up sorry
Craig you know what I mean it's like but
wow but yeah so total it's like 10 but
yeah I just even growing up like we were
the only ones that were that big really
and like now I it's like unheard of I
don't know any that have had that many
kids yeah it's it's funny that you talk
about you know uh fertility and so on
because I I just came back remember
earlier I told you that I I was having
dinner with Jordan Pearson in Budapest
and the reason why we were both in
Budapest is uh we had been invited to
speak at a a summit called The Budapest
demographic Summit which was organized
by the president of Hungary uh to talk
about the dwindling fertility rates in
the west right so as as you probably
know Pearl uh the replacement rate in
other replacement rate means you know
how many kids do you have to have on
average in order to at least it's it's
actually 2.1 but three you're over it so
if you're at three you're doing good and
actually I feel a great sense of
existential guilt because because my
wife and I only have two children so I
haven't done my part in spreading the
god sad genes in retrospect I think had
we I think we should have started
earlier my my wife and I have been
together for almost 24 years now but we
only started having kids nine years into
our marriage uh and so what we our our
two kids now I would have loved for them
to be number three and four rather than
number one and two but it's too late now
I gu I'm guessing you don't have any
kids
right would you do you want to have kids
yeah I do want
kids good good excellent make sure to go
over that 2.1 so that we can keep our
societies thriving yeah I want four
ideally but we'll
see very good very
good but yeah but it's like unheard of
though now so I'm like I don't know
how like I don't know Society is going
to be a weird what do you think's going
to happen you're you seem smarter than
me what do you what do you what do you
think going to happen in the next like
50 years in terms of family Dynamics in
terms of what that's a very vague
question what what I'll I'll hone it in
like yeah hone it in please in terms of
society like you know if we're below
replacement now and people aren't
getting together like do you think
societies are going to like crumble like
what do you think is going to happen
well I think what's going to make
Society scrumble beyond the fact that
you're not meeting for you know
replacement rate I think that uh I don't
I I I don't want to turn dark in our
conversation but I think that there are
certain realities that are happening in
the west that are terribly uh
problematic right so uh the erosion of
many of the values that have defined the
West
right freedom of speech scientific
Integrity presumption of innocence
journalistic Integrity you know
apolitical institutions like the FBI the
military the justice system these should
not be politicized so all of these
things that made the West the you know
the great social experiment that it's
been and and I can speak about this
because I come from societies that don't
have those values right I come from the
Middle East so I'm seeing all of those
values being eroded hence one of the
reasons why I erode the parasitic mind
also to compound the problem I'm seeing
a open immigration policy that is
disastrous because when you have a
completely unvetted open border policy
in terms of letting people who don't
share the foundational values of your
Society think about earlier when we were
talking about assortative mating birds
of a feather flock together in terms of
the fundamental value well I could apply
that principle for cultures right where
if you're the host nation you want to
let in people who share those
fundamental values with you if you're
letting in one 1 2 3 4 10 million people
who come from societies that are
perfectly opposed to those foundational
values you're going to have trouble so
that's why today for example you're
seeing Global Jew hatred I'm I'm
Lebanese Jewish and and I'm I'm afraid
to walk in some places in Montreal
Canada wearing a star of David that's
probably what worries me the most about
the next 30 to 50 years you know I'll
tell you I used to be very Pro
immigration cuz my dad he had a company
and he would bring over people from
India a lot and I was like this is
amazing like you get my they work so
hard you know we don't have the supply
here amazing but then I moved to
London I know where you're going with
this then I moved to London I got to say
I have a very different opinion now
because you kind of see the the issues
that come like I kind of see what you're
saying because um you almost lose the C
culture of a place like I I feel like
I've been in London I've barely been
around British people exactly well
because because what people do is they
fetishize the the the positive aspects
of cultural enrichment there is new
smells and spices that are used and new
Cuisines and new languages and all those
things are wonderful I mean I don't have
to be lectured I speak four languages I
don't have to be lectured about the
beauty of that's so cool cultur thank
you uh right okay that's great but there
is a downside of cultures which is some
cultures think that homosexuals should
be thrown off buildings some cultures
think that the world is much better with
no Jews in it some cultures think that
little girls clitorises should be cut
off when they're five those cultures are
not equal to other cultures that don't
practice those things that don't believe
in those values and by the way this is
something that I again I talk about in
the parasitic mind because the the
parasitic idea of cultural relativism is
exactly that which says who are you to
judge the values of other cultures
that's a form of imperialism how dare
you with your on your high horse say
that you you you shouldn't be allowed to
cut off the clitorises of little girls
that's their culture that's their
religion shut up racist no if you're a
moral person you should have enough of a
moral compass to say I give a about
your culture when it comes to cutting
off clitorises of little girls that will
not be tolerated in our culture if you
come to our culture and you come with
those beliefs we're going to ship you
back faster than you could say hello so
I think that's one of the problems in
the west which is people don't have the
self-confidence in standing up and being
proud of their cultural heritage right
and that's going to lead to major
problems over the next few decades well
and then you also see this like anti-
white campaign like it's just completely
anti like ever since I was a kid like I
remember like straight white men being
evil and that was I didn't believe that
but I I heard you hear that all the time
and there's so much stuff that's
literally like it's literally
anti-white oh yeah oh yeah and I always
and you want to hear something funny
yeah I get neo-nazis who are super
prowhite who accuse me of being
anti-white and I say are are you kidding
me I have spent my entire career making
fun of all that white supremacy stuff
that you hear in Academia but that again
shows you how parasitized people's M
people's minds are and I I I've never
seen it as as crazily as over the past
month I've I've been attacked by every
single possible group you could think of
now usually the attacks have been around
Jew hating so the progressive left hates
the Jew
because there's huge anti-Semitism in
Academia right you know Palestinians are
the oppressed and the mean Jews are the
oppressors then you've got the right
Neo-Nazi types who are Ultra right who
hate the Jews Jews will not replace us
so then they hate the Jews then you've
got all the Islamic folks who send me
hate because you know die Jew gas the
Jews gas the Jews so so the Jew hatred
is coming at me from every possible
Direction but hopefully eventually
goodness will prevail I hope so the well
what that that that that got you stopped
in your tracks sorry I don't know no
because I was thinking like I just it's
interesting because in the west or in
America more you have this idea that if
you go into a country you have to adapt
like the American mentality but it's
like what I've seen as a contrast of
that in London you don't really have to
exactly and so it's as a matter of fact
it's it's it's racist for you to expect
us to adopt the host nation right
Society you know what there is all these
protests every day I walk down the
street and there's these protests okay
and they're always protesting something
this girl was an immigrant protesting
for free
housing exactly it's like I mean
I'm an immigrant here but I wouldn't you
know I wouldn't ask for free housing I'm
like crazy lady but that's what happens
with the sense of En lement with the
sense of victimology and that's exactly
the type of stuff I talk about in the
parastic mind right so I mean uh you
know let's no longer have standardized
testing in in in universities because
you know that's racist let's not have a
meritocracy because you know that's
white supremacy let you know let's no
longer give grades because grades is a
form of ableism I mean it's insane right
I mean it's it's ridiculous so hopefully
we can turn the tide around yeah I'm not
I'm I'm I'm very hopeful for myself but
I'm not hopeful for
Humanity well at least you'll be happy
as as the ship goes down thank you I
will um could you tell the people where
they could find you sure so uh I've got
a website gadad sad.com uh you can get
my all of my books I have many books but
my last two are the parasitic mind and
the sad truth about happiness sad Saad
uh I'm on Twitter I'm on Instagram I'm
on Facebook it's usually g a DS a d God
sad super fun talking to you and I hope
we can do it again yeah thank you very
much for coming on guys make sure you
like the video that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams also get yourself
a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt yes yes I believe I won't get
into this but this is the root of all
evil women should not vote take it away
get your T-shirt today and also um make
sure you leave a comment and let me know
who you want me to have on next time
thanks for watching we'll talk to you
next time